that's odd  what's wrong Herschel this cabbage has a  face on it  hmm i love ball tuesdays and wednesdays  and thursdays and hey you're not  touching your food yeah I am look you're  being weird again  okay I'm sleeping with a horse I'm not  sure when it happened  was it the clearance at the sunglass hut  or the sale at the fashion boutique I  bought 27 cases of lipstick  they weren't even my color the food  court lady got mad at me cuz I ate all  the General Tso's when did this Mall  madness begin  slinky I just hacked in you better have  this money Marty but I don't have a dog  no no no no not a pound puppies hey how  can government website sure is wrong can  I sniff your foot  sniff your butt